amy kimmel finally brought back his mean  tweets segment featuring a really long  list of a-listers including tom holland  kevin hart tom hanks dakota johnson and  many more and let's just say that peter  parker himself had the perfect response  to one not-so-nice twitter user  tom hanks is so sweaty and top gun  get a shower you smelly little dwarf  that i take personally  this is no hate to hannah waddingham  because i'm sure she's lovely  but she looks  insufferable  well tom horan is an absolute ranger  and he's also spiderman  dakota johnson has some serious notes  happening  cool  this is just wrong shaq's penis is kevin  hart  you talentless ball sack  i take offense to this only because a  ball sack holds a ton of talent  it has half of the dna to create human  life that's a pretty fascinating thing